vorstellungsgespräche deutsch lernen mit
dialogen
lerne mit uns nimm einen bleistift und
papier
bist du bereit los geht's guten morgen
guten morgen
willkommen
wie kann ich ihnen helfen
guten morgen
willkommen
wie kann ich ihnen helfen
ich habe ein vorstellungsgespräch mit
herrn müller
natürlich
wann haben sie den termin
um halb neun
einen moment bitte
sie können sich setzen ich werde herrn
müller informieren
vielen dank vielen dank
bitte bitte
guten morgen guten morgen guten morgen
guten morgen
herr müller wartet auf sie bitte kommen
sie rein
[Musik]
herr müller wartet auf sie bitte kommen
sie rein
danke
danke guten morgen herr müller
guten morgen herr müller guten morgen
guten morgen
darf ich ihnen herr meier vorstellen
vielen dank
vielen dank bitte bitte
schön sie kennenzulernen
ich bin herr müller willkommen schön sie
kennenzulernen
ich bin herr müller willkommen danke es
freut mich auch sie kennen zu lernen
danke es freut mich auch sie kennen zu
lernen
bitte nehmen sie platz bitte nehmen sie
platz
willkommen herr meier vielen dank dass
sie gekommen sind
vielen dank dass sie mich zum
vorstellungsgespräch eingeladen haben
herr meier ich habe ihren lebenslauf
gelesen
sie haben ein interessantes profil herr
meier ich habe ihren lebenslauf gelesen
sie haben ein interessantes profil ich
möchte ihnen ein paar weitere fragen
stellen
ich möchte ihnen ein paar weitere fragen
ja gerne deshalb bin ich hier ja gerne
deshalb bin ich hier erzählen sie mir
ein wenig über sich selbst
erzählen sie mir ein wenig über sich
selbst
ja sehr gerne
ich bin ein guter und engagierter
arbeiter
ich bin auch sehr kreativ und habe viele
gute ideen
ich arbeite auch sehr gut im team
ich freue mich immer über den kontakt
mit kunden
vielen dank ich möchte sie gerne auch
persönlich besser kennenlernen
wofür interessieren sie sich dafür
interessieren sie sich
ich interessiere mich für tanz und musik
ich lese gerne
ich lese gerne ich reise wirklich gerne
ich reise wirklich gerne das ist sehr
interessant sagen sie mir bitte was ihre
letzte arbeitsstelle war
[Musik]
das ist sehr interessant sagen sie mir
bitte was ihre letzte arbeitsstelle war
natürlich
ich war
führungs berater in einer versicherung
natürlich
ich war
heroes berater in einer versicherung das
ist interessant warum möchten sie bei
uns arbeiten
das ist interessant warum möchten sie
bei uns arbeiten
ich möchte gerne bei ihnen arbeiten weil
ich in ihrem unternehmen viel neues
lernen kann
ich möchte gerne bei ihnen arbeiten weil
ich in ihrem unternehmen viel neues
lernen kann
nennen sie mir drei schwächen und drei
stärken
okay das sind meine schwächen
ich bin ein bisschen ungeduldig
ich warte nicht gern ich bin ein
bisschen ungeduldig ich warte nicht gern
ich bin auch zu perfektionistisch
alles muss immer perfekt sein
ich bin auch zu perfektionistisch alles
muss immer perfekt sein
manchmal bin ich auch zu kritisch mit
mir selbst wenn ich einen fehler mache
das sind meine stärken das sind meine
stärken
ich bin immer sehr pünktlich und kommen
nie zu spät
ich bin sehr kommunikativ und kann sehr
gut im team arbeiten
ich bin sehr fleißig ich gehe erst nach
hause wenn ich mit der arbeit fertig bin
hause
wenn ich mit der arbeit fertig bin
warum sollten wir uns für sie
entscheiden
[Musik]
warum sollten wir uns für sie
entscheiden
weil ich viel erfahrung habe
weil ich sehr schnell lerne
und weil ich sehr motiviert bin
perfekt haben sie noch fragen perfekt
haben sie noch fragen ja ich würde gerne
wissen wie der arbeitsplatz hier
aussieht
ja ich würde gerne wissen wie der
arbeitsplatz hier aussieht
wir haben hier ein gutes arbeitsumfeld
wir arbeiten gut zusammen
wir arbeiten gut zusammen das team ist
sehr hilfsbereit
das team ist sehr hilfsbereit
das gefällt mir
wenn sie keine weiteren fragen haben
würde ich ihnen gerne das büro zeigen
super ich möchte gerne das büro sehen
perfekt los geht's perfekt los geht's
dies ist der konferenzraum
dies ist der konferenzraum er ist der
projektleiter
er ist der projektleiter
guten morgen
das sind die büros das sind die büros
sie sind sehr schön und groß sie sind
sehr schön und groß
ja danke
ja danke hier ist der pausenraum hier
ist der pausenraum hier können sie ihre
mittagspause machen
hier können sie ihre mittagspause machen
super ich kann mein eigenes mittag essen
mitbringen
ja natürlich ja natürlich
dies ist der ruheraum dies ist der
ruheraum cool
es gefällt mir sehr gut es gefällt mir
sehr gut
dies ist der serverraum dies ist der
serverraum hier sind alle unsere
informationen
hier sind alle unsere informationen
das ist interessant das ist interessant
dies ist ihr büro dies ist ihr büro
das ist perfekt das ist perfekt also
habe ich den job
also habe ich den job
ja ja super super
gratulation gratulation
vielen dank vielen vielen dank für das
gespräch
wir freuen uns auf sie vielen dank für
das gespräch
wir freuen uns auf sie vielen dank herr
müller vielen dank herr müller und
bitteschön schönes wochenende
danke gleichfalls danke gleichfalls
[Musik]
vielen dank für alles vielen dank für
alles wir sehen uns am montag
auf wiedersehen wir sehen uns am montag
auf wiedersehen ok schönes wochenende
und gratuliere
ok schönes wochenende und gratuliere
möchtest du gratis online deutschland
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniert
und videos jeden sonntag
[Musik]